komm aber erstmal auf einen neuen Streit
um den Deutsch Iraner Adnan Tabatabai
das ist nämlich der Berater von
Außenministerin Anna-Lena baerbock und
ausgerechnet er und seine Familie
pflegen enge Kontakte zum brutalen
molaregime im Iran ziemlich unfassbar ja
und auch anderen tabatai selbst wirbt
immer wieder mit Verständnis für das
brutale Regime dass er als eine
regulierte Demokratie verharmlost
dennoch verbreitet der WDR seine Thesen
unkommentiert zitiert den jüngst wieder
als Iran Analysten zu den Frauen
Protesten in Teheran und als Berater von
beerbock hat er nun mal enge Kontakte in
die deutsche Politik wir haben Politik
ist für die tabatabais auch nichts Neues
sein Vater war ein Vertrauter des
iranischen Revolutionsführers
Sonderbotschafter des Irans und er
schmuggelte sogar Waffen und Drogen für
die Mullahs nur aufgrund seines
Diplomaten Status wurden diese
Straftaten nicht verfolgt und dabei
kämpfen gerade zehntausende Frauen und
Männer gegen sie auch in Berlin so eine
dem für die Freiheit im Iran gab es
bislang noch nie 80.000 Menschen kommen
am Samstag in der Hauptstadt zusammen
dutzende grün-weiß-rote Flaggen wen auf
der Straße des 17 Juni in Berlin sie
wollen Solidarität mit den mutigen
Menschen im Iran zeigen
da denn seit dem Tod der 22 Jahre alten
Kurden Mascha armini durch die
Sittenpolizei im Iran da kämpfen ja nun
10.000er Iraner in ihrem Land für die
Freiheit unser riskieren dabei ihr Leben
Iran beinahe 12.500 festgenommene
unfassbare 250 Tote durch Polizeigewalt
trotz der Brutalität gegen Demonstranten
kommt es im ganzen Iran seit Wochen zu
heftigen Protesten seit dem 16 september
dem Tag an dem mother Amini durch Gewalt
der iranischen Sittenpolizei getötet
wird wird der Aufstand gegen das
mulla-regime nicht mehr leise bekommt
revolutionäre Züge in Berlin kommt
10.000er um den Protestierenden Menschen
im Iran beizustehen es reicht wir sind
seit 40 Jahren in der Islamischen
Republik und wir wollen Freiheit für
unser Volk und für unsere Familien
zurück im Iran immer wieder sind es
Studentinnen die mutig protestieren sie
nehmen öffentliche Kopftuch ab geben
sich kämpferisch wollen dass sich etwas
ändert selbst diese jungen Schulmädchen
demonstrieren schon marschieren
selbstbewusst mit ihren Kopftüchern in
der Hand
aber auch Männer gehen auf die Straße
für die Selbstbestimmung von Frauen und
gegen das Herrschaftssystem im Iran mit
uns nicht sagen diese mutigen Menschen
im Iran die Anteilnahme weltweit ist
groß auch in Deutschland in der
Hauptstadt sieht der protestszug von der
Siegessäule durch das Regierungsviertel
und den Tiergarten immer wieder erklingt
der Slogan Frau Leben Freiheit immer
wieder fordern die Demonstranten den
Sturz der dortigen Regierung aufgerufen
zu den Demonstrationen hat der in Kanada
im Exil lebende iranische Aktivist komm
mit immer Lion
wir wollten eine große Kundgebung in
Europa veranstalten um die europäischen
Länder und die europäischen Regierungen
auf die Situation im Iran und die großen
Anstrengungen des iranischen Volkes für
Gerechtigkeit und Freiheit in unserem
Land aufmerksam zu machen
nach Wochen des Aufbegehrens reisen die
Unruhen im nicht
abreisen das ist kein Aufstand mehr das
ist kein Protest mehr das ist eine
Revolution das ist die Botschaft die wir
von den jungen Menschen im Iran erhalten
haben dass dies eine Revolution ist und
sie nicht aufgeben werden diesmal gibt
es große Hoffnung diesmal gibt es viel
Beständigkeit und wir sehen diesen
Protest und diese Revolution in
verschiedenen Formen in jeder Ecke des
Irans der Westen muss anerkennen dass
dies eine Revolution ist die stattfindet
aus allen Himmelsrichtungen kommen die
Menschen am Samstag nach Berlin doch in
Gedanken sind alle im Iran bei den
Menschen die für die Freiheit ihr Leben
riskieren
[Musik]